alright give us the lowdown how likely
is this them to pass well there's about
535 members of Congress that's still get
a say in this pin before it is
officially sealed but look there's
really three major hurdles that the
White House is dealing with now that
negotiators have finalized the top line
points of this deal first is public
perception already this was an unpopular
issue in the United States trade
generally is not just with Democrats
which are traditionally against these
agreements but also with Republicans a
July pupil had only thirty-six percent
thinking that this was a good deal for
the country so the white house needs
outreach right now you're going to see
public comments from the Department of
Agriculture today from the President or
going to see a blitz of radio and TV
interviews so that's one area the other
is losing losing key allies PIM in order
to even start the process of this they
needed to clear the way to have this
bill considered on just an up-or-down
basis in the months ahead so they have a
group of allies that are already set
right now that's a key component of this
the other thing PIM campaign politics
this is obviously coming right in the
heart of a presidential campaign season
and the White House needs to ensure that
while there will be a lot of rhetoric
tossed around that doesn't seep into
Capitol Hill where some of their
supporters start wavering whether or not
they want to give this to go ahead when
they vote on it early next year hey I
feel you don't tells you something about
the process involved when the details of
the deal aren't necessarily one of the
three things that are the obstacles are
there specific details in the deal that
the president can look to and say this
is going to help American business look
top-line the administration has been
hammering already eighteen thousand cuts
to tariffs this should open some doors
particularly in the agricultural sector
in Japan and Canada for the automotive
industry in places like Brunei and
Vietnam there are specific areas here
but pen one of the most interesting
things about yesterday when this deal
was sealed before anything was released
I already have three dozen statements of
opposition from environmental groups and
progressive activists big business is
already pushing support for this soap in
no matter what this deal looked like
there were already entrenched interests
that we're going to take one side or the
other so right now it comes for the
administration to kind of push a
top-line point to make supporters
comfortable one of the interesting
things Pam Ford Motor Company big
business obviously a big supporter of
this deal ford motor company because of
currents
manipulation already out yesterday in
opposition of the deal they need to
ensure that big business big companies
stay behind them on this that was an
early warning sign all right Phil give
you about 15 seconds who is the point
person from making this pitch to
Congress it's the President himself when
it comes to the details it's their Trade
Representative Mike Froman but President
Barack Obama if he wants this to be the
legacy ceiling deal that it is he's
going to have to sell this himself him